[Music]
all right so what do you guys think
about what do you guys think about evil
must these days okay so there was the
whole I open up the factory and we going
against the whole quarantine thing right
and rubbed you know a certain
demographic up the states or that just
the world I guess the wrong way because
we're supposed to be quarantine and
usually really trying to get back to
work and then like then there's like the
whole his son where's the daughter wait
this is fine our daughter
it's child the name the name yes the
name doesn't give away the gender at all
true yeah it's an equation and then yeah
and then you just been doing a lot of
like cryptic tweeting lately right I
mean it's like all the time she told
yeah I like how his tweet control how
his tacos for Tesla so far it's [ __ ]
funny
I mean it's fun but like maybe not so
fun for if those who are investing this
house love it true well yeah recent
tweet he did this wine which was the red
pill and which was what does the red
pill do was it the matrix
no no I know where it's from but like
what was originally wakes you up to the
reality and the blue pill just keeps you
in dream state okay but not only is it
about the reality vs. dream state thing
from the matrix this is a reference from
the matrix if you didn't know but it's
also now got ties to the red and blue
parties of politics and so now a lot of
people are taking visit that from the
Rose know whether she's like the red
rose and the word red pill heart mm-hmm
as red pill red pill means more is that
Republican or Democrat no there's a lot
of meanings to red pilling now it just
means like awake to this thought right
but then but then a lot of different
groups use it like I know there's a
there's a like within the guy movement
when you get red pill it's kind of like
um how like they're being controlled by
feminism or whatever like embrace and
sell ISM yeah and itself that taking the
whole there's also like red pilling for
the minority community where if you red
pill minorities such as like Candace
Owens and whatever what they're saying
is like we've been brainwashed to kind
of choose liberalism and only choose
liberalism and then you can't even
question that fact so then when
minorities are red pill it's kind of
like oh now I'm found questioning why
I'm forced to be a liberal or contacting
right yeah and then there's also like
the other red pilling there's some all
right red pilling right and then there I
don't know if the left uses red pilling
a lot yeah no but and then there was one
more to about just waking up to some new
way of thought but yeah there's multiple
ones yeah generally though the red pill
I think on a mainstream level is found
upon oh I don't know well he's like
living in LA I feel like that's the case
these are the I think California is
pretty blue well he's that's how they
paint it yeah that's how they painting
yeah and so to add to this Ivanka Trump
answered and said taken Oh which then
masturbated even more I yeah she's like
I didn't like the sequel's though yeah
what does that mean like I took it well
it's probably but now representing what
you were saying though right Liam Neeson
movie it's like we just put in a bunch
of [ __ ] Chum in the water and she's
basically put internet and and taking
time she and her name represents I mean
she's a trump so it just it carries so
much weight if she Jung
now everyone's going oh what I was
thinking is not been validated it's a
right wing it's a right wing so what's
we yuan thinking where's Ilan could have
been referencing matrix he could have
just watched it but I think what you
know was talking about was the whole
like hey we all have to be on lockdown
don't question anything like ting oh cuz
that's what he was that's really this
was coming right out of him trying to
open up his his factory and everyone saw
on these gonna kill people and he's like
actually if you look at a lot of the
data
remember he was on Joe Rogan saying a
bunch of stuff like that so that's what
I thought it meant I thought a good
amount of his employees are just robots
right no like you the robot like the
people the people there that are working
there just like watching over the
machines and making sure that they're
performing well but like I don't know
from what I've heard it was just like
there's not that many people in the
factories because a lot of the machinery
is already doing
if Ilana is talking about like how we're
not allowed to question like the laws or
just the the the quarantine orders and
all those things I think that it makes
sense to me because you take the red
pill to wake up to house if anyone says
anything your people are just out to get
you and question does not mean accept or
anything question just means just
question it yeah we can even have a
discussion about it because they're like
well you don't care about people dying
and all this stuff and it's like I get
it it's a tense time but I think you
want to constantly question things
because you want to see where the you
just got a communication with army
nurses and all this yeah get more
thoughts and ideas out sprout new things
and then and pave the way for the future
you don't want to be like they already
told us already so so you don't want to
[ __ ] listen
and then just shut up until they tell us
to open up again right it's like well
that's not how our system should work
because it's supposed to be a
communication a back and forth yeah so
now with these two kind of like you know
saying their piece on it another person
entered this little tweeter silly mix
its McDonald's yeah none other than the
creator of matrix
Wow both of you this is my America right
here yes my America everybody say
whatever you want and then people have a
right to be like y'all [ __ ] you I love
it
and then you didn't respond to this
directly but he did add one more little
thing and he said this did you seriously
just take both pills what the [ __ ] is
wrong with you when you take dayquil and
nyquil at the same time what does that
even mean anymore he's trolling he's
trolling but yeah but it's just it
sparked a little like you know like
Twitter started you know going off on
like what's this all mean where's elan
going with this and that's just i
thought it was interesting
are we allowed to say that Ivanka Trump
is hot yeah she's pretty hot she is
pretty hot and you say that right now
yeah did I see it I think she's very hot
bad she's like the most out of all the
brothers and sisters like the most
likely to take over the family business
and she's pretty sharp and all that
stuff seems like it I mean the way she
represents herself and freaks out in
public and all that yeah it seems like
she's what's the son's name jr. Don jr.
I like Baron I don't like jr. very much
he's kind of I don't know much about him
I don't know it just feels kind of like
oh yeah I'm not that into the Erica
Trump yeah I just really just go by
always Baron looks kinda like he was
sleepy during the whole acceptance
speech remember we need the youngest one
yeah the one that they had with his new
wife yeah yes the tall kid it's tall now
I guess yeah yeah I mean why is the n33
wait yet Ivana
and then another eye and then
milania's by when he's with now right
[ __ ] but he's been with her since like
they ain't about 90s or I don't know I
don't know but the other two ex-wives
look rough now dude okay we can't
[ __ ] that we can't like oh by about
your beauty standards alright Joe um so
there's pretty old ladies though you be
with Trump and hang in there who's the
pretty old lady oh that someone named ya
right now baby why watch what porno you
like Betty White she's a pretty old lady
should I start doing porn you would you
would watch I trying to [ __ ] her it's so
goofy I'm just kidding I don't know who
I'm talking about
you know baby white yeah it was another
lady it was another chicken red and the
red movie red with Bruce Willis who the
[ __ ] is that
I thought you meant Oh read later
titties Helen Mirren Helen Mirren bro
Helen Mirren who's Helen man she's
pretty Dame Helen Mirren got it goin on
bro who's that she's a hot older lady
I'll tell you that
oh she's enough oh she's the lady that
walks out in that one what about the
what about crumpled old grumpy old men
what about it that grandma oh yeah she's
not about glencove Sophia then close I
don't know if I ever thought Glenn Close
with Glenn Close you know I never got
into it I was never close closer I know
there's a lot of them out there I'm
sorry yeah so our people outraged
traitors always outraged I just I
thought yeah this is interesting I think
Elon is playing a funny game and I don't
know I think my take on it - it's like
Elon is the head of Tesla right and
Tesla is anti-oil
you know in in theory because it's yeah
yeah so then but it's really not -
because you have to plug him into a wall
which is generated by coal it's true
most yeah that's like we're using
electric and I'm like where do you think
electric comes from buddy yes so far and
I think that's the interesting part is
that I think
Elon has for a long time been kind of
associated with more like the Liberals
and like oh he's you know trying to do
like you know he was a hero
climate change and all these kinds of
things right and and then now he's doing
all these cryptic messages that kind of
lean towards the other direction and I
think I just find that kind of
interesting and I didn't even know was a
conservative thing that red belt no no I
didn't even know people saw him as a
conservative or they know they don't
know because they think that red bill
all because they're taking the
conservative red pill right like you own
was the guy that goes and drones 'roger
droga Rogan podcast and smokes weed and
stuff you know yeah and then and then I
don't know where you kind of does like a
180 turn now you know and blows my mind
because a lot of conservative states
they made weed legal before the two
super liberal states of California in
New York wait which could services and I
thought Colorado started it I thought
that was a conservative state yeah it's
not a rented it's a are there red states
that are they have legalized marijuana I
Texas read about it yeah compared to the
blue no then I was watching this Dean
word so they uh Jay Leno just got access
to a cyber truck oh this has nothing to
do at parties but it's just uh I just
saw a little clip and then this made me
like even more regardless of whatever
his political position was but he was
asking him about how like how strong the
the trunk is just like made out of my
steel and he's saying the the glass is
bulletproof
oh and then and then Jay Leno's I Oh why
would you do that nigo I was like why
wouldn't you what do you want all of
your trucks to be bulletproof to a
pistol and I'm like I saw this clip
didn't he say cuz it's [ __ ] tighter
whatever is so great it's [ __ ] dope
I'm like that is [ __ ] dog that [ __ ]
that's why I like deal on muscles
because he did that flamethrower thing
and then planned out his boring company
I think all that shit's great I probably
could troll like a living toys like
SpaceX is amazing it's like the [ __ ] I
even though they're shooting a Tesla
into space right yeah he just likes to
[ __ ] around that's all tight yeah we're
actually launching today it's a it's
happening in like an hour
oh yeah 322 something yeah I made that
up no you're right it was a weird it was
like 322 is like so specific
[Music]